[Music]
I write down these Egyptian accounts for
whosoever believes in such stories I
heard other accounts at Memphis and I
visited Thebes too and heliopolis for my
inquiries I have decided to record
exactly the narratives that have been
taught to me just as I heard them
the priests told me that Egypt was well
governed and prospered greatly from the
time of King ramsanitus until the reign
of his successor chaops for chaops
reduced the people of Egypt to utter
misery first he prevented their access
to the temples so that no one could
sacrifice in the sacred places then he
forced all the Egyptians to labor on his
tasks the extracted stone blocks from
Mountain Quarries in the arabian-facing
desert and were made to haul this
stonework to the Nile
the blocks were transferred across the
river on boats where other work Crews
received them the Egyptian populace
worked in gangs of a hundred thousand
men with each team tasked to work for
three months for 10 years the people
were very oppressed by this work first
they constructed a paved roadway for the
stones to be dragged along and the
building of this approach was only
slightly less arduous than the
construction of the main pyramid 10
years of Labor went to the making of
this road and the underground Chambers
on the hill where the pyramids now stand
King intended these Chambers to be his
tomb and he directed a channel from the
Nile River around his burial place
took a further 20 years to construct the
main pyramid its base was made to a
square plan with each side 800 feet long
then its height was raised to a further
800 feet the whole Outer surface is
polished stone that is precisely fitted
in place there is no block visible that
is less than three feet in length
[Music]
this pyramid was constructed like a
Stairway with successive tears or steps
when this inner form was completed the
Workman used levers made of short wooden
logs to raise the rest of the stones
into position first they heaved up the
blocks from ground level to the first
tier of steps then they raised the stone
again to the next level above the first
tier
on each tier they used new levers or
they reused existing devices to easily
lift and convey the finished Stone to
its required elevation and position
I'm not certain about this account but
this was the construction method has
explained to me I remember what one
Egyptian interpreter said to me
said that the equivalent of sixteen
hundred talents of silver had been spent
on supplies of simple remedies and for
onions and garlic to flavor their food
if this were the case then think how
much wealth was expended on the iron
required for their tools or the
provision of their food and clothing
then think how much time was spent in
the construction itself including the
hearing and carrying of stone blocks
then there was the excavation of the
underground Chambers which I suppose
must have been a prolonged and difficult
project
[Music]
foreign
what gift do you get for the god king
who has everything every Coronation Day
the people of Egypt would shower the
Pharaoh with gifts it must have been
hard to choose perhaps they should have
waited a couple of Millennia to try
bespoke post bespoke post is a monthly
membership club delivering a box of
awesome top shelf goods from under the
radar Brands it's free to join and you
can skip a month or cancel any time
every month they introduce members to
cool new products outdoor gear barware
home and kitchen goods clothing and more
based on a preference quiz that you fill
out every box of awesome has around 70
dollars worth of goods inside it and
costs you only a fraction of the value a
great box to recommend is the Weekender
it comes with a fantastic bag perfect
for any occasion especially outdoor
activities ninety percent of the
products come from small Brands many of
which are based in the United States for
example the Damascus steel knife in the
Forge box is made by Buck and Bear
knives located in Pennsylvania you'll
get a box of awesome assigned to you
before it's shipped you'll get preview
of what comes inside to decide whether
you'd like to keep it swap it for a
different box or skip the month entirely
for no charge you only pay for what you
want so to get 20 off your first box of
awesome click the link in the
description and enter voices20 at
checkout or go to bespokeepost.com
forward slash voices20
foreign
when we visited Egypt the ruler was King
Ptolemy but for most of its history
Egypt was ruled by native Kings King
chemis of Memphis ruled for 50 years he
constructed the largest of the three
pyramids which are considered to be one
of the Seven Wonders of the World
the pyramids filled the beholder with
astonishment and wonder due to their
immense size and the great skill
displayed in their construction they say
that more than a thousand years have
passed from the building of this pyramid
to our own lifetimes but other writers
claim that the pyramids were constructed
more than 3 400 years ago and after all
that time the stones still remain in
position preserving their original form
in a structure that has not collapsed
is said that the Stone from the pyramids
was conveyed over a great distance from
quarries facing Arabia it's also claimed
that they built Mounds to raise the
blocks into place since cranes had not
been invented at that time these
construction Works must have been on an
enormous scale and yet the surrounding
landscape consists of nothing but sand
there's no choice of Mounds or evidence
for the working of stones this is
remarkable and it gives the impression
that the pyramids were not produced by
the slow labor of men there must have
been some sudden creation they look as
though some God had boldly set them down
upon the empty Sands
certain Egyptians make a Marvel out of
these circumstances they claim that the
construction ramps were built from salt
or salt-like materials
then upon completion the river was
diverted to dissolve the Redundant
Mounds the construction Works were
therefore completely effaced without
great human effort however I do not
believe a word of these accounts the
entire material for the Mounds was
obviously brought in and raised by a
massive labor force therefore the same
labor force could have removed and taken
these materials back to their place of
origin they say that 360
000 men were employed in constructing
this pyramid and the entire structure
was completed in 20 years when King
chemist died his brother kethron
succeeded the throne and ruled for 56
years while writers agree that kefiran
built the second pyramid at this site to
emulate his predecessor this structure
equaled the first pyramid in the skill
of its design but it was smaller since
the length of its base was only a star
day on each side an inscription on the
larger pyramid gives figures for the sum
expended on its construction the writing
records that the sum equivalent to 1600
talents was spent on vegetables and
remedies for the workmen a smaller
pyramid has no inscription but has some
Stone steps cut into one side
these two kings built the pyramids to
serve as their tombs but when the time
came neither of them were buried in
these structures for the multitudes had
suffered great hardships in the building
of these monuments and they were filled
with anger towards their kings due to
many cruel and violent acts therefore
they openly threatened to tear apart the
bodies of those who had made them suffer
and cast their remains out of their
tombs consequently when each ruler laid
dying he beard his close Kinsmen to bury
his body secretly in an unmarked place
the third pyramid is far smaller than
its predecessors but it faster passes
them in the skill of its construction
and the great cost of its stonework the
base length of each side of this pyramid
is three plethora on the north side of
this pyramid there is an inscription
stating that its Builder was mycerinus
they say that this ruler was indignant
of the cruelty of his predecessors and
therefore aspired to live an honorable
life devoted to the welfare of his
subjects
he built the first 15 tiers of the outer
edifice from the Ethiopian dark stone
which can be seen at thieves but he
filled out the rest of the structure
with the same stonework used in other
pyramids there are also three more
pyramids Each of which is one plethorum
long on each side these pyramids each
follow the same general construction as
the larger examples except for the
smaller Dimensions the Egyptians say
that these three pyramids were built for
the wives of the three rulers that I
have mentioned
foreign
ly agreed that the pyramids far surpass
all other Construction in Egypt this is
not simply due to their massive size but
to the great skill displayed by their
builders in fact they say that the
architects of these monuments are more
deserving of admiration than the Kings
Who provided the means for their
construction for The Architects use
their genius and ambition to achieve the
project while the Kings merely employed
great fortunes they had inherited and
committed other men to Grievous labor in
the build
laughs
when ideas gallus was the prefect of
Egypt I accompanied him on a journey
along the Nile as far as scyene and the
frontiers of Ethiopia
and they visited these places with
gallus while he was in the company of
numerous friends and soldiers
leaving Alexandria we came to Babylon
where there is a Roman Fortress
belonging to one of the three Legions
that now guard Egypt
there is a ridge extending down from the
encampment to the Nile where water is
conducted up to the camp from the river
using wheels and screws more than 150
prisoners are employed in this work and
from this fort the pyramids can clearly
be seen for they are positioned on the
far banks of the river near Memphis
Memphis was the royal residence of the
Egyptians it's close to Babylon and only
three shueni from the Nile Delta Memphis
contains temples one of which is devoted
to apis it was the same deity as Osiris
this place is very Sandy due to the
dunes that continually being heaped up
by strong winds
at this place I saw some of the sphinxes
that have been partially buried by the
dunes one was buried up to its head
while the others were only half visible
from this site a traveler could guess
the power of the sandstorms and
understand the dangers that might befall
the man traveling on foot towards the
temple
the city of Memphis is large and well
populated it is second only to
Alexandria in its size and significance
there are many different races and
people living intermixed in this city
just like Alexandria
[Music]
40 stadia from the city there is a ridge
on which numerous pyramids have been
constructed these are the tombs of Kings
three of the pyramids are noteworthy and
two are even numbered among the Seven
Wonders of the World these two pyramids
are about a stadium in height they are
quadrangular in shape and their height
is a little greater than the length of
each of their sides high up on the outer
surface of these pyramids there is a
removable block this slab is
approximately midway between the sloping
sides or the North Face of the pyramid
when this stone is pulled out it reveals
a long-slanting passage leading to an
inner vault
these two pyramids are positioned close
together and were constructed on the
same level but further up the sloping
ground there is another pyramid which is
much smaller than the other two this
Pyramid has a reduced size but its
construction involved much greater
expense
from its foundations almost to the
middle of its facade the pyramid is
constructed from Black Stone this is the
stone which mortars are made from it
comes from the mountains of Ethiopia and
is therefore transported across a great
distance it is sought after and
expensive because it's an extremely hard
stone that is dense and difficult to
work into shape
one of The Marvelous things I saw at the
pyramids must be mentioned there are
many heaps of chipped Stone lying in
front of the pyramids some of these
stoned fragments have the same shape and
size as lentils but other heaps formed
from splinters that resemble the husks
of winnowed chaff it is said that these
Mounds are the remains of fossilized
food left by the ancient Builders of the
pyramids and this certainly seems
possible the Quarry which provided stone
for the pyramids is located within sight
of the structures it is on the far
Arabian side of the Nile next to a rocky
mountain called the Trojan height
[Music]
I must mention the pyramids of Egypt but
only for the sake of curiosity for they
are Superfluous and foolish display of
wealth on the part of the Egyptian kings
generally thought that these rulers only
built the pyramids to deny funds to
their successors or to hinder those who
are plotting against them or else to
keep the Common People occupied the
Kings displayed great and meaningless
vanity in these Enterprises and the
remains of several unfinished pyramids
are still in existence
there is a Great Pyramid in the district
of austinaway and there are two at
Memphis not far from the Labyrinth which
I will describe two more pyramids stand
at a site that is now filled by Lake
moweris this artificial lake is merely a
vast excavation but the Egyptians claim
that it is one of their most remarkable
and memorable achievements
the points of the pyramids at Lake
moweris are said to Tower above the
surface of the water
the other three pyramids are at Memphis
and their Fame has reached every part of
the world these structures are
immediately visible to people traveling
along the Nile in either direction they
stand on a rocky elevation in the desert
on the African side of the river nearby
is a village called busiris where the
local people are well practiced at
climbing up the pyramids
these Sphinx stands in front of the
pyramids this object deserves to be
described more than the pyramids yet the
Egyptians pass over it in Silence the
inhabitants of this region regard it as
a deity they believe that King harmeas
is buried inside it and the entire Stone
edifice was transported to this site
but the Sphinx was in fact carefully
fashioned from the Native Rock the face
of this monstrous creature is painted
with red ocher as a sign of reverence
the circumference of the head when
measured across the forehead is 102 feet
the length of the monument is 243 feet
and its height from its stomach to the
Cobra on top of its headdress is 61 feet
the largest pyramid is made of stone
taken from quarries on the Arabian side
of the Nile it is said that 360
000 men took 20 years to build it the
time taken to build all three pyramids
was 88 years and four months
the following authorities have written
about these structures
Herodotus ahuamorous duris of Samos
aristagarus Dionysus antistanis
Demetrius demotalis and Appian not all
of these writers agree which Kings were
responsible for what constructions
Justice is therefore intervened and the
Kings who aspired to the greatest
displays of vanity have had their names
confused or forgotten some of the
writers recalled that 1600 talents were
spent on radishes garlic and onion for
the workers no traces survive that
reveal the purpose or operations of the
pyramids built around the site are
scattered far and wide Stone fragments
shaped like lentils
these objects resemble the gravel found
in Africa on the rocky edge of the
Sahara
The crucial problem with the pyramids is
how the masonry was lifted to such a
great height some think that ramps of
soda and salt were piled up against the
structure as it was built then after its
completion those ramps were dissolved
flooded by water from the river others
believe that elevated Bridges were built
of mud bricks and when the work was
finished the bricks were taken by people
to build their houses
but another method is thought to be
impossible the idea that the Nile could
have flooded the site and blocks were
floated into place this is because the
River Flows at a much lower level
there is however a well-like passage in
the largest pyramid that is 86 cubits
deep
it is said that water from the Nile was
conducted into this passage via a
Channel thales of melitus devised a
method to measure the height of the
pyramids he realized that the shadow
cast by a structure indicates its
relative height such should the wonders
of the pyramids
but the last and greatest of the
pyramids prevents any further
speculation involving the wealth and
Grandeur of Kings for the third pyramid
which is the smallest and most admired
was built for a mere prostitute named
rodopus
and why should we admire the pyramids of
these ancient Kings when Julius Caesar
paid 100 million sister sees merely for
the ground where his great form was
built
[Music]
of course I was already acquainted with
the land of Goshen from the time when I
first went to Egypt for it was my
purpose to see all the places which the
children of Israel had encountered on
their Journey from there to the Red Sea
as they went forth from the land of
Ramses
Memphis still contains the palace that
Holy Joseph often used to visit six
miles from there on the banks of the
Nile is the Throne of Moses and Aaron
these Thrones are positioned on a High
Ridge and many steps lead up to the two
turrets one of these turrets has a roof
that Moses used to climb upon when he
addressed the children of Israel during
their oppression the other turret has no
roof and it was used for prayer
all around this site is the plane where
the children of Israel made bricks about
a mile away close to the riverbank is
the village where Holy Mary stayed with
the Lord when she went into Egypt
there are many pyramids in the 12-mile
stretch between Memphis and Babylonia
these buildings were constructed by
Joseph for the storage of grain
heliopolis is 12 miles from Babylonia
and at its Center is a large piece of
ground which contains the Temple of the
Sun
The Garden of the sun is in this place
and the great column called The Beaumont
this is where the Phoenix used to settle
after 500 years of life
[Music]